welcome back to Washington journal for
the next 65 minutes our guest Amy
Goodman of Pacifica Radio she's the host
of Democracy Now which is a nationwide
broadcast thanks for being with us here
front page of USA Today is an article
that caught your attention this morning
the headline is radios historic change
smaller headline is amid consolidation
fear of less diversity and choice and
anthony de barros writes that a USA
Today analysis of government and
industry data on station ownership shows
radio is undergoing an unprecedented
wave of consolidation taking it from a
kitchen table culture of mom-and-pop
business to one at home in the
boardrooms of the nation's largest
companies and this continues but the
changes have also raised concerns that
radio as big business is hurting
diversity of content for listeners as
well as diversity of ownership in the
front office as a radio person this was
your first choice
tell us about changes in the radio
business well I think that this is very
significant when we talk about media
conglomerates and how it's affecting the
news that we hear
I'm from Pacifica Radio which is
non-commercial and I think that that
really makes all the difference we're
not beholden to any large corporation
and in these these are mega corporations
where you have smaller radio stations
being bought up by bigger and bigger
ones you have really a homogeneous a
ssin of a message of an agenda that
comes out and so even though it may seem
like there's more and more channels and
cable that there's a there's more
diversity and radio in fact there's
really less diversity both in terms of
color in terms of message and I think
that there has to be a really
reinvigoration of the whole public media
movement like Pacifica not beholden to
any corporation only to the listeners
how do you see how is news affected by
this corporate ownership o in all sorts
of ways I think the idea of towing a
corporate line we see in terms of the
lack of criticism for example of
corporations in fact I just overheard
the last part of your conversation where
you were talking about the CNN story
that where there's been so much
criticism
but over and over again we see
corporations cracking down on not
getting out true messages about what's
going on today on the radio show that I
do on democracy now we're taking on
Chiquita banana one of the largest
banana corporations in the world based
in Cincinnati people may have heard
about this story a story of the
Cincinnati Enquirer doing an amazing 18
page supplement exposing Chiquita's
labor practices all over the world and
also talking about corporate bribes that
were going on in places like Colombia
but Chiquita cracked down there their
questions about how the journalist
obtained his information although I
don't think they're serious questions
about what that information is and so
the Enquirer has backed off is going to
pay Chiquita ten million dollars and
they have pulled the story it's almost
impossible to get anywhere pulled it
from their website all references to it
go to a place that's just an apology to
Chiquita but we're seeing this more and
more with corporations like Monsanto and
others when they crack down on the flow
of information and these large media
conglomerates are often owned by these
very corporations or share the same
ideology there's a a chart in this
article we'll come back to the Chiquita
story a little bit later but these
there's a chart with a story about radio
showing the top ten station owners and
they're listed by a 1997 revenue but it
shows for example CBS owns 160 stations
Chancelor media 108 jcore Communications
204 stations cap star Broadcasting
Partners 299 stations and Clear Channel
Communications 196 stations that's the
chart but in this article it talks about
various effects of this ownership and
one at lists several alaska amy goodman
about the minorities are losing ground
how does corporate ownership affect
minorities in radio well there are also
laws and rules of the FCC where we're
losing ground everywhere which is the
idea that with deregulation there is
less regulation of insuring that there
is a kind of reflection of society in
the
Media so that when you have a city that
is majority-minority like for example
New York City a majority
african-american and Latino we should
have a press corps that reflects that
picture and we don't and with regulation
you get that or at least you can start
trying to achieve it my co-host on
Democracy Now Juan Gonzalez who writes
for the New York Daily News just came
back from the National Association of
Hispanic Journalists conference in Miami
and they're setting back their deadlines
for achieving some kind of parity in the
newsroom because they see that they
can't do it and I think we have to have
regulation we have to have we have to
very carefully monitor who is
represented in the media because I think
it will determine the news stories that
are chosen and the perspectives that are
put out before we leave this story one
other item that lists here is an
effective this is less local content
with content why is that significant we
see that more and more and I think
that's bringing the voices of grassroots
activists out from around the country
the more you have these national and
international mega corporations you're
not going to get that local flavor
reflected which are what people are
doing on the ground every day that other
people can identify with and then get
engaged participate Amy Goodman is the
host of Democracy Now on Pacifica Radio
with a Spore the next hour first up is
Sturbridge Massachusetts good morning
good morning Lou good morning Amy hi
listen I've got a pretty simple question
first and I'd like to follow it up with
the comment but I'll be brief looking
directly at my Webster's ninth new
Collegiate Dictionary I see democracy
government by the people rule a rule of
the majority a government in which the
supreme power is vested in the people
and exercised by them
Amy when back in 1996 oh and by the way
I want to say hello to all of my friends
on the Free Republic internet site this
is Jim Gibbs from Sturbridge hi y'all
back in the last presidential election
and unprecedented 70% of the voters
nationwide said that they wanted Ross
Perot included in the presidential
debates our Republican and Democrat
duopoly kept him out of those debates
now 170 percent when a mandate that
unprecedented says they want something
as insane an issue as important as a
presidential debate and the Democrats
and Republicans conspire to preclude the
will of the people do we indeed have
democracy no that's a very good question
it wasn't only Ross Perot also Ralph
Nader of the Green Party and there were
serious challenges there of course I
think that the political spectrum has to
be widened and that the people that sit
on these boards that decide who is
included in this debate have to
represent more than the Democratic and
Republican Party and that's when we will
see an invigoration of the electoral
process I agree a couple of the articles
that you clip from the Washington Post a
small news story but the lead editorial
both about Nigeria the news story US
delegation starts Nigerian visit and it
begins a US mission to Nigeria the
highest level such mission since the
annulment of the 1993 elections
triggered political chaos here arrived
in a sign of West African and a sign of
the West African countries rapid
reintegration into the world community
the mission is the latest indication of
a dramatic reopening in Africa's most
populous nation after the desolate death
last month of general Sani Abacha the
country's military ruler and have a
scramble by world leaders to prod
nigeria toward democracy and political
stability that's the small news item but
it's also the lead editorial a
washington post today today in lagos
today Nigerians learn what their chances
of breaking free from the corruption and
dictatorship of the army has fastened
upon them for most of their country's
four decades of independence general is
it Abu Bakr mm-hmm just Salim Abu Bakr a
successor to strongman Sani Abacha who
died of a heart attack a month ago is
expected to lay out a timetable and
rules for the possible restoration of
democracy
International story we talked about this
morning why's this significant
this is a story that I've been following
quite closely and is significant for the
world Nigeria is the most populous
country in Africa you've had a military
dictatorship there for more than a
decade in the last five years it's been
Sani Abacha who recently died and now
another military dictator has moved in
and you have a high-level State
Department delegation that just went to
Nigeria is meeting with the military
dictator I think the u.s. relationship
with Nigeria has to be exposed because
for too long they have been shoring up
these dictators whether they're sunny
Abacha or the man right now abdul salam
abu bakr the question this week is
whether among others Massoud Abiola will
be released from prison he is the
presumed winner of the presidential
election of 1993 and he was imprisoned
in 1994 we have had his daughter hafsat
Abiola who lives in the Washington DC
area on our show a number of times she
speaks around the country about the need
for democracy in Nigeria also people
like Wohlers Sri Lanka the winner of the
Nobel Prize for Literature well-known
pro-democracy activists who basically
has a ransom out for his head he has if
he is to return there he would be tried
and most probably killed this is what
Nigeria looks like today people may know
ken Serra we WA who was a well-known
playwright in Nigeria he was a leader of
the Ogoni movement there this was a this
is a group of people the Ogoni people
hundreds of thousands who are fighting
the large oil corporations like shell
like Chevron corporations that
unfortunately I think determine US
policy and that's why the US has
continued to have a supportive
relationship of these dictators and so
this high-level delegation that's led by
Thomas Pickering that's come from the
State Department he just met with Abu
Bakr we'll see what comes of that it
looks like Massoud Abiola may be
released there's tremendous
world pressure on him from the so called
leaders including the United States Kofi
Annan of the UN to renounce his claim on
the presidency we've only gotten reports
about what he's saying we don't know yet
what he's saying maybe we'll know when
he gets out but if we want to support
genuine democracy I think the first step
has to do with pressuring these oil
companies and through them the Nigerian
government and perhaps that's oil
sanctions claremont california good
morning hello I'd like to speak to the
Pacifica representative there I've been
an active supporter of the Peace and
Freedom Party for years and years and
years and years perspectives I helped
start it in 68 and we get practically
zero coverage of our candidates on the
news with KPFK s matter of fact a are
any of the Californian pacifica stations
you know as a matter of fact ABC CBS and
NBC cover Peace and Freedom Party
candidates more why don't you explain
who the peace and freedom I've
complained I've gone to them we've sent
letters we've sent delegations and they
will not on the news cover anything our
candidates have to say tell her before
you go tell us about what the parties
stands for we're Democratic socialists
we call herself feminist sometimes we
live up to feminism a little better than
other times but we come out of the 60s
and we broke with the Democrats over the
war in Vietnam and the particular type
of racism which was going on in 68 which
police departments were routinely just
going through black people's homes and
shooting them up you know we started her
own party we're disgusted with the
Democrats and I'm disgusted with
Pacifica and its complete unwillingness
to cover any of our candidates been
around for ages we routinely get at
least 2% of the vote but we sure don't
get 2% of the coverage on KPFK or KPFA
news thanks for the call Amy Goodman
well I haven't spoken to you so we'll
have to speak after the c-span program
but he's talking about the California
stations Pacifica is a network of five
stations that Pacifica owns and then
community radio stations around the
country where our news and democracy now
is broadcast KPFK is in Los Angeles and
KPFA is in Berkeley other than the
publication's that we normally see here
in the morning you have brought others
what has caught your attention in these
publications that we may not see
regularly well these are alternative
publications that I think it's important
for people to go to because well there's
just the control that the corporate
media has on information I think can
only be challenged by alternative forms
of information this is extra which is a
newsletter put out a news magazine put
out by fairness and accuracy in
reporting and the latest issue is the
headline is the myth of the liberal
media and they commissioned a study that
despite what the what the corporate
media puts out and also what generally
people think that if you look at the
people the Talking Heads on television
that the large majority of them are from
conservative institutions also they just
did a study looking at the press cores
views towards issues like like the
environment issues like corporate
control like health insurance and what
they've generally found is that the the
media is to the right of the general
public and I think that might surprise
many who talk about a left-leaning bias
in the media so I find that it's a very
useful tool to turn to to turn to fares
extra magazine one of the articles
inside is the headline the right-leaning
rolodex for sources journalists most
often turn to think tanks of the right
got a call in quickly Los Angeles good
morning good morning I'm I called it on
the liberal line because I am what I'd
call a true liberal a what is called
today libertarian but what for most
American history was called the liberal
I have it strikes me that the
authoritarians on the left and the right
ignore the government's thumb prints
now all the social pathologies that are
afflicting the country and I think with
respect to the authoritarian left
there's a focus on on the concentration
of media power where there is a complete
blindness to the fact that that our
government school system is far more
appropriate for the Islamic Republic of
Iran or Communist China the difference
of course is that you have a single
monopoly in this case a government
that's indoctrinating our youth as
opposed to many many corporate interests
they certainly do have their spin and
certainly do have concentrations of
power but nothing the rival of
concentration power of the government
and it's children that we're talking
about c-span basically reviewed a book
called the lies my teacher told me by
not professor James Lowen who documented
this from an anti-authoritarian Left
perspective that is he said he pointed
out that the treatment the American
civil rights movement according to a
survey of the 12 most popular history
textbooks in American high schools
basically promoted the government the
federal government's role for gallantly
he says and I think I believe it
basically giving black Americans
secondary a supporting role giving the
federal government the number-one rule
as well as the treatment in the Vietnam
War as well as a whitewash of American
Indians throughout American history Matt
thanks Los Angeles Amy Goodman well I'm
a great believer in public education and
I think it has to be strengthened I
think we have to pour more money into it
around the country I think it is the
place where if any place we can start to
equalize society it starts with all kids
having the same opportunity so that
that's what I would respond I am very
concerned about the corporatization of
education about corporations moving in
and providing syllabuses our syllabi
maybe you say
of you know corporations like Exxon
putting out a syllabus on on the
environment I think we have to have
corporate free education I'm concerned
about the television like the form or
wittle communications going into schools
where you can't turn down the newscast
during commercials that's sort of the
trade-off for getting the the newscasts
in the classroom for free I think kids
have to expand be creative and all be in
school together and that education
should be free we just saw the cover of
the July issue of extra this is an
article from the May issue that's the
think tank monitor what's in a label
right-wing think tanks are often quoted
rarely labeled and Michael dole knee
rights for the third year in a row
conservative or right laning think tanks
in nineteen ninety-seven provided more
than half of the major media's
think-tank citations according to fares
third annual survey of major newspaper
and broadcast media citations in the
nexus computer database think tanks of
the right provided 53% of the citations
while progressive or left-leaning think
tanks received just 16% of the total
citations we're just talking about that
and what's another of the magazines that
you've brought another one is let's say
I was looking at a merge a very
interesting piece it's Haiti's constant
pain of people I think it's Haiti's
constant pain but it's about a man named
Immanuel Kant stomp and it's a written
by Katie Ornstein who has lived in Haiti
for quite a long time and he was the
founder of frappe which was the Haitian
paramilitary death squad that during the
coup in Haiti from 91 to 94 was
responsible for so many of the deaths in
Haiti now you would think that he would
be behind bars I mean after all the US
government said they were going in to
wipe out these thugs and rapists and
murderers well the fact is he's living
in the United States in Queens he has
full approval of the US government he
was released from a detention center
here and it is really no surprise
considering that frappe the paramilitary
death squad that was set up in Haiti was
also set up with the help of the Central
Intelligence Agency
and the Defense Information Agency the
DIA these are very serious charges they
were exposed by Alan Aaron in the Nation
magazine and so a manual constant now
runs free today in the United States and
if the president is serious about law
and order and taking criminals off the
street I think he has to directly
address I've asked about it at the White
House and the State Department how it is
that Emanuel constant is allowed to walk
the streets of the of New York City and
of this country this is the photo that
is with this article and emerge the
article is called safe harbor with a
question mark
Fulton New York good morning yeah I'm
mainly a conservative but lately I've
really liked what I've seen and I'd like
to finish my comments before I get
caught up here um what I see is you know
the tobacco companies have lied to
Congress okay but yet they're above the
law Newt Gingrich refuses to even
investigate them even though he's put a
slush fund up to investigate the unions
and then you got Dan Burton who's
running an investigation which under the
scope of investigation he should be
investigating the tobacco companies for
the 50 billion dollar tax giveaway that
tobacco companies got for millions of
dollars in campaign funds the same
tobacco company has paid Ken Starr a
million dollars a year for the last four
years and if you look at it you'll find
out that Ken Starr wasn't making that
much money from the tobacco companies
beforehand and I wonder have the tobacco
companies paid can start for this report
that they're supposedly going to give to
the Congress because if you find if you
look into the Minnesota case you'll see
that the backhoe companies have paid
lawyers to lie about their lawyer client
privileges and they've had information
underneath these things and then I look
at and I see that you know what do you
what do we say to our kids when our kids
look at us and they say hey wait a
minute now everybody's talking about
tobacco companies lying to Congress but
yet because they're giving Newt Gingrich
millions of dollars that he just lets up
walk scot-free that's a very good
question the whole issue of corporate
control of Congress if you look at for
example public citizens studies of which
corporations gave which politicians
money campaign contributions and I think
we should stop calling them
contributions
was just talking to a man who's
considering running for governor of New
York on the Green Party ticket al Lewis
he's grandpa Munster most people know
him as and he was saying you know we got
to stop saying contributions I mean it
gives you the sense of something
charitable they're bribes and I think
that the viewer that just called in put
his finger on it I mean these people are
bribed it's very direct and it's got to
stop and that leads directly into the
issue of campaign finance reform and
Congress has dogged lay stopped any real
meaningful campaign finance reform
Detroit Lakes Minnesota good morning
good morning I find it most amusing to
listen to this conversation I've
listened to c-span for quite a long time
but I think that the individual PACs are
some of the largest contributors to our
problem and I think the Asian influence
has been a real big problem that hasn't
really been investigated it probably
will never really be investigated and
then there's a pack called AIPAC which
is uh has probably the most influence in
Washington DC as I see it Minnesota if
you see that as the problem what do you
see as a possible solution well I think
they should really have a little
diversity and some of the comments and
some of the the individual people who
are discussing these problems we see the
same faces and the same names all the
time and personally I think the Zionist
influence is the strongest in our
government right now and I think that
for the sake of this country I think
that and for the sake of Israel and for
the sake of Jewish people in general I
think they should back off and take a
look at see what they're doing well I he
referred to AIPAC the American Israeli
political action committee it is a very
powerful lobby in Washington and I think
it leads us into israeli-palestinian
texe what's going on with the UN right
now Benjamin Netanyahu is attempts to
expand the control Israeli control over
all of Jerusalem
these are very serious issues and if
there's any possibility that there will
be peace in the region I think that this
you know this clearly has to change one
of the other journals that I brought
actually is the progressive magazine and
on the cover it says the death of Oslo
and talking about the Oslo Accords an
interview with Robert Fisk Robert Fisk
is a reporter for the independent you'll
rarely hear him in the US media he's
been based in Beirut for more than two
decades been voted the best
correspondent foreign correspondent by
British editors and reporters for years
now a man who has taken great risks he
was there at the Econo massacre when the
Israelis opened fire on the southern
Lebanon camp where so many people were
killed we have to talk about foreign
policy from the perspective of the truth
and I think that in the case of Israel
and in the case of the Palestinians we
rarely get the truth I would recommend a
book called the image image and reality
of the palette Israeli Palestine
conflict by Norman Finkelstein has
written some very interesting work there
I guess you're looking at a picture of
Robert Fisk who has very important
things to say about what's going on in
in the Middle East and if Israel wants
to survive and if the Palestinians are
to survive there has to be a different
route that is taken and clearly what
Netanyahu is doing particularly in
blowing up Palestinians homes or even
seeing this more and more in the
mainstream media which we rarely did
before because Washington had so backed
Israel now there's a shift and because
Netanyahu has not accepted some of what
Clinton and Madeleine Albright the
Secretary of State have been pushing for
and because I think the US media very
much follows the Washington line for the
first time you're seeing regular
articles in The New York Times
talking about the blowing up of homes of
Palestinians talking about an Israeli
Arab doctor and not being able to buy
land and really showing the two-tiered
system in Israel and I think that's very
very important along with this
photograph of Robert Fisk and the
progressive in the July issue this
article by Matthew Rothschild begins
Robert Fisk is Britain's most highly
decorated foreign correspondent he's
received the British international
journalist of the Year award
seven times most recently in 1995 and 96
his specialty is the Middle East where
he spent the last 23 years and in your
comments you said we don't see read him
much here why not well I think his voice
has been blocked out unfortunately when
people are critical of Israel in this
country you'll often see them labeled as
anti-semitic I mean I am Jewish and I
have and I'm very proud of my heritage
and my religion but I'm very critical of
Israel and I think that we have to stop
smearing people with that taint saying
they're anti-semitic when they criticize
a state in this case the State of Israel
Edgartown Massachusetts good morning I
want to comment on the Saran Gyatso
report of CNN at 9:00
I think this anger and indignation is
coming there rises from their report
comes I believe from the belief that our
military is incapable of such a moral
lapse that we would not use chemical
warfare against an enemy that we are
more civilized and say Saddam Hussein
our people in our media have forgotten
that in the history of warfare all the
United States is endorsed itself in
virtually unrestricted chemical warfare
it's in a weapon of war more cruel and
inhumane than napalm which we dropped
and virtually unlimited quantities on
Vietnam or Agent Orange which we use the
default a huge areas of Southeast Asia
and it's caused thousands to form
fetuses and birth defects and children
we are self righteous people often quite
unwilling to see ourselves as others see
us with frequently blinded to the harm
we do people in the pursuit of what we
deem our national interests I say I
think that there are time but the New
York Times reported that Melvin Laird
said he was Secretary of War under Nixon
he said that we did have saran guess and
Vietnam well why would we be surprised
if we
use a nerf get against these people I
just kind of can't understand the
brouhaha that's going on Amy good well I
hear the passion in that viewers voice
and I wonder if he doesn't have some
experience himself during Vietnam in the
Vietnam War no that's a very important
point and I think that the issue of what
CNN did has to be looked more carefully
at I'm very concerned about it as well
although I don't know all the details I
haven't yet gotten a chance to speak
with April Oliver who is the producer
although we hope to interview her on
Democracy Now or to speak with Jack
Smith or Peter Arnett but this whole
issue I think that the viewers right
that there's a sense there's a kind of
outrage that it's even possible and that
sort of starts the reaction against this
kind of peace and we do have to look at
all those forms of chemical warfare that
have been used by the United States I
think it's very interesting some of
April Oliver's allegations saying that
it was when Colin Powell and others said
that they would you know limit CNN's
access to the military when that
pressure came down very hard that CNN
said you know this is a public relations
disaster and we have to look at that
relationship between mainstream
reporters in this country the White
House press corps the Pentagon press
corps the relationship between them and
those that they cover these institutions
and the trade-off that these reporters
make to get leaks to get access I don't
think it's an access it's a trade-off
that is worth it and if you're not going
to get that leak from the Pentagon that
often might not be true and they use you
a reporter as a conduit to get out some
false information without putting their
name to it it'll often be an unnamed
source if we if these reporters continue
to make these deals we're never going to
get honest reporting I think that the
the media has to be or our slogan on
Democracy Now is the exception to the
rulers we can't tow the Washington
agenda we have to challenge it we have
to be there as watchdogs every day the
New York Times has this headline CNN
employs pointedly ask how
escaped purge Felicity behringer writes
hundreds of angry Cable News Network
staff members in the network's Atlanta
headquarters and were and more calling
in from CNN bureaus around the world
took part in two meetings at which some
demanded to know why the network's top
managers stayed on the job after last
week's apology and repudiation of its
report the American military had used
nerve gas in a 1970 mission in Laos
Murfreesboro Tennessee good morning good
morning this first time I've ever gotten
from I'm really proud to be on the
c-span glad you did you mind yeah I had
a comment firown' that's good and I
agree with what you said about the
campaign plans as far as the
contributions column bras but it's
pretty much what it is but I think the
best way to reduce the incentive for
robbery is to cut down on the amount of
authority people up there have I mean if
they've got all this power corporations
have incentive to try to buy them off
and that's where a lot of the problem
comes from because if you don't play
ball with them then you don't get tax
breaks or you get hammered and over
several things about companies that
don't necessarily play bone and they
don't they get they get hit on these
things a couple other things I think
full disclosure would be you know a good
idea and biggest thing I run I ran for
Congress in the 96 as a Republican fifth
District intesity and I had no no party
backing really because the Republican
Party didn't really think I was chance
to win and I couldn't get any money but
the farm I saw and I still see is that
the local news media would not cover the
issues at all I mean if I talked to them
and gave a reporter an interview and
talked about issues it never got covered
I mean all the time the one to cover was
scandal and things like that so there
was a race in the 6th district where
there's a ton of mud playing well they
love that right but they wouldn't
covered the one I was going at all
thanks that's a very very important
point I mean when you look at the cost
of campaigns the largest chunk of the
money that is spent is spent for media
is spent for television advertising and
I think there is an incentive for the
corporate media actually to cover very
little because then the media then the
candidates will spend more money
ads in California during the
gubernatorial Democratic gubernatorial
contest that they just recently had the
media almost covered this race until the
very end not at all and the bulk of the
way people learned about these
candidates was through their ads we have
to remember that the airwaves are all of
ours the media doesn't own the airwaves
they lease the airwaves and I think that
these corporations have an absolute
responsibility to the American public to
make those airwaves available for people
like you who want to participate in the
political process and they should be
made available for free it should not be
determined by how much money a candidate
has personally or how much they can
raise from corporations it's a it's a
system that is the greatest threat to
democracy completely undermines
democracy and people feel it all over
they become alienated and we have to
just turn the tide on this and we have
to the problem is is that it's not just
the corporations in you know Congress
that control things let's not forget
that the media themselves are the most
powerful corporations and so they fight
on these issues as well Amy Goodman is
host of democracy now on Pacifica Radio
she's from Bay Shore New York has a BA
in anthropology from Harvard and
Radcliffe and at various times has been
a freelance reporter for the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation monitor radio
Australian Broadcasting the BBC NPR the
Latin file in Latin American news
service and one of the notes that we
have on the internet this morning is
from Mel Moll and he asks who and what
supports Pacifica financially if
multiple sources who and what is the
principle support well the principle
support is listeners the whole idea of
Pacifica it was founded in 1949 after
World War Two because a man named Lew
Hill who'd gone out to California felt
there had to be a media network out
there that was not beholding to
corporations but run by journalists and
artists and so Pacifica was born the
first station was KPFA in Berkeley and
then slowly these other stations came on
board in Houston Texas KPFT WPF W in
Washington and New York its WB
i KPFK in Los Angeles and that idea that
we're not beholden to corporations but
we're beholdin to the listener and so
80% of our funding comes from the
listener we have fundraising drives that
drive people crazy three to four times a
year where we open the phones and we say
please call in and support us and so
that's how we get by we also get some
funding from the Corporation for Public
Broadcasting which funds public radio
and television in this country how many
stations we have five stations that
Pacifica owns but then about 60 stations
air the Pacifica Network News and about
25 stations air Democracy Now which does
show I host a grassroots national daily
political news magazine I'm gonna take
another call from Rahway New Jersey and
give you a chance to fix the earpiece
well way good morning good morning this
is I'm a first-time caller to c-span and
apparently you've been having a
discussion on campaign contributions and
campaign reform and I have before me a
1990 this is a November 24th New York
Times article listing the top 10 donors
of 1996 and while corporations have been
slammed I wonder if I could read off the
top ten donors how much they paid and to
what party they paid it - sure number
one is Philip Mars 4.2 million 21
percent went to the Democrats 79 percent
of the Republicans number two the
American Federation of State County and
Municipal Employees four million ninety
nine percent of the Democrats a mirror
Association of trial lawyers of America
3.5 million 85 percent of the Democrats
national educational Association 3.3
million 96 to the 96 percent of the
Democrats Teamsters Union 3.2 million 96
percent of the Democrats laborers Union
3.1 million 93 percent of the Democrats
United Auto Workers 3 million 99 percent
of the Democrats United Food and
Commercial Workers 2.9 million 99
percent of the Democrats International
Brotherhood of Electrical Workers to
eight million ninety-eight percent of
the Democrats American Medical
Association two point eight million
twenty three percent of Democrats 77 to
the Republican this is a list that
you're reading from where I am reading
from the November 24th New York nine
Times article by a Jill Abramson mm-hmm
and it lists of the top ten donors and I
think it should be made known that the
problem with it was that corporations
are indeed paying for political power
but if you look and just use basic
mathematics you will see that the labor
unions are paying a tremendous more than
anyone else and they're getting
something for their money well I don't
know about that list I think if you look
at corporate money in politics it is a
good deal more than the labor unions but
I'm glad you brought up the labor unions
because there is a major strike going on
right now actually it's the GM strike
the General Motors strike that has idled
more than a hundred thousand workers but
I also want to apologize for using the
USA Today story first although I was
just so intrigued by the radio story
because well I offer a shout out to the
Detroit newspaper workers who have been
out two thousand of them for more than
two years striking against the owner of
USA Today but the GM strike is a very
serious one that's going on it's about
really the future of the labor movement
about a large corporation like General
Motors outsourcing using subcontractors
that are not Union that they can you
know pay lower wages to not pay benefits
to and so these men and women are out on
the front lines and they have been out
for more than a month now and I think
that shows a real resurgence of the
labor movement in this country
Grover North Carolina good morning I've
got two or three beats I want to direct
to a me into you also one of them is why
don't y'all go with closed caption on
your TV so the people I hear is hearing
impaired and also a me on the CNN you
News report that were they fired the two
reporters at I wish more news media
would take responsibility and when they
do make a mistake come out and publish
it not on the back page and a little
bitty column put it on the front page
where they made the mistake yet I agree
with you there and I'm not sure if this
falls into that category but I totally
agree with you I wanted to raise even
another story about corporate control
over reporters I did an interview about
a month ago with two reporters one of
them named Jane Acree who worked for Fox
News in Florida and they did this series
of reports on the Monsanto Corporation
particularly on our BGH which is bovine
growth hormone and how Monsanto uses
them injects them into cows and then
they produce more milk they were
concerned about simply about does this
have an effect when they had give their
kids cereal in the morning should they
know that there is bovine growth hormone
in the milk should it be labeled do the
grocery stores label it and they did
this very interesting investigative
series Fox promoted it heavily and then
right before it was to air the Monsanto
Corporation threatened them with a
lawsuit and they pulled the series they
didn't get to air it they didn't air it
then they worked on I don't know how
many dozens of rewrites of that script
despite the fact that had been promoted
advertisements and put out in the rest
of the media and the lawyers had signed
off on it they had said this is an
excellent report and they never did air
that story and we see this more and more
as a clamp down on information and that
is what I am most concerned about I'm
concerned that if a reporter makes a
mistake they should admit it but I'm
also concerned about all the
investigative reporters who are trying
to do good work but that door that
window is closing and it is very
difficult to get that work out there
which is why we need independent media
you mentioned earlier this story that
you'll be talking about I think on
today's program about Chiquita Brands
and in the business section The
Washington Post is a particular angle of
that story and the headline is a
cautionary message on voicemail Chiquita
story shows vulnerability of the popular
systems and Devon Spurgeon writes in
Cincinnati what began as an ex
josè of Chiquita Brands International by
a hometown newspaper has turned into a
cautionary tale for corporate America on
how a modern innovation voicemail can be
stolen and misused just as easily as
corporate documents and trade secrets on
a Sunday morning and early May Chiquita
executives awoke to find what were
alleged to be their own voicemail
messages reprinted in the pages of the
Cincinnati Enquirer and an 18 page
pullout there's a quote from Stephen
Warsaw Warshaw whose Chiquita's
president and CEO he says our business
and my personal privacy were violated in
the most extreme way I mean my children
leave me messages I don't want the world
to know their grades you mentioned this
earlier what's this story about that
she'll be talking about today well it's
a very interesting story on May 3rd
Chiquita banana found itself the subject
of an 18-page supplement in the
Cincinnati Enquirer that's pretty
incredible in itself just because the
headquarters of Chiquita is in
Cincinnati and it is a real company town
Procter & Gamble is also headquartered
there I spoke out at Xavier University
last year and I walk down the campus and
oh there were the Carl Lindner physics
labs for example he's the CEO of
Chiquita there's a lot of control
exerted by Chiquita there and so you had
the Cincinnati Enquirer amazingly enough
doing an 18-page supplement looking at
all sorts of issues I'm just looking at
my notes from our show today saying that
Chiquita secretly controlled dozens of
supposedly independent banana companies
saying that Chiquita executives bribed
Colombian officials that Chiquita called
in the Honduran military to evict
residents of a farm village soldiers
forced the farmers out at gunpoint
saying that despite its pact with
environmental groups to abide by
pesticide safety standards Chiquita
subsidiaries have used pesticides in
Central America that are banned in the
United States
releasing harmful toxic chemicals into
farms killing at least one worker in
Costa Rica these are very serious
charges to reporters did it Cameron
mcwhirter and Mike Gallagher now after
this 18 page supplement ran and I assume
it ran altogether rather than a series
so that Chiquita couldn't stop it if it
ran in a series and I
that cincinnati enquirer poured millions
of dollars into this year-long
investigation did a tremendous amount of
fact-checking on it
well after it came out and we don't know
all the details Mike Gallagher who is
the lead reporter on this said that he
had gotten his information from an
unnamed executive within Chiquita now we
are only hearing the reports that maybe
there was not a real executive but he
had hacked into the voicemail system
somehow or he had somehow gotten the
voicemail and that's what you're reading
about today in the Washington Post now I
don't know what's happening there I do
know that a prosecutor has been that a
prosecutor is now investigating Mike
Gallagher and these charges but that a
special prosecutor has been appointed
because the prosecutor in Harris County
his name is joseph deters whose office
is in leading the drive to investigate
Gallagher has received campaign
donations from Chiquita
so Chiquita controls a lot that's going
on there and I think we have to be very
careful before we make any accusations
but about the accusations against
Chiquita activists have been talking
about this for years there has been
scattered reports all over Central
America there was just an international
banana Alliance conference in Brussels
where hundreds of activists and
corporate executives went to come up
with guidelines around how these banana
corporations should operate but we're
talking about death we're talking about
bribes and while they have appointed a
special prosecutor to investigate the
reporter have they also appointed a
special prosecutor to investigate
Chiquita banana I think that that you
know is something that has to be looked
at as well so we interviewed the head of
banana link in Britain which is a
grassroots group that looks at the
banana corporations and also we talked
to grassroots activists in Cincinnati
that have a kind of ad hoc group that
looks at Chiquita and its practices
abroad next call is from Atlanta good
morning good morning
I want to enquire a little bit more
about Amy's a funding for Pacifica Radio
apparently you know she she thinks that
that corporation or the her competition
all the other radio stations are funded
by this evil octopus out there called
corporations we're about how much of her
funding comes from the people who listen
to her show and how much of it comes
from public money well as I said about
80 percent more than 80 percent come
from listeners who listen to the show
and then under 20 percent comes from the
Corporation for Public Broadcasting
which is taxpayer money so the
overwhelming majority comes from
listeners calling in and making their
contributions of fifteen or twenty five
or fifty dollars Fullerton California
good morning morning relative to that
nerve gas situation and CNN I got to
believe they should all be terminated
all implicated parties and then secondly
I did have another point if I could
uh-huh
miss Goodman he almost made me nauseous
there when you claimed that some useless
the media wasn't liberal for crying out
loud
you know I can prove to you that the
media's liberal with one little scenario
if you let me this situation with
homosexuals and them and they're
distorting of the English language and
calling themselves gay gay means to be
ho happy to be joyful it does not mean
to be homosexual so my question to you
is if the media isn't liberal who care
who curried this message to America to
begin calling homosexuals gay to which
too many Americans now do well I think
people have a right to identify
themselves and to describe themselves as
they want to I don't think that is the
media I think that's people themselves
who are gay and lesbian who decide how
it is that they want to be described
what are several the other publications
you brought that we may not see here on
a regular basis Ozzie magazine is a very
interesting publication that comes out
of Boston that is independent that
brings the voices of people like Noam
get out Noam Chomsky who is a leading
dissident in this country who we rarely
see in the mainstream media Noam Chomsky
by the way who actually is the person
who I learned from about an issue and
one of the articles that I chose today
which was the Indonesia story he has
been talking about Indonesia for the 32
years of the dictatorship of Suharto who
was just forced out by a pro-democracy
movement in the last few months which is
a truly amazing story amazing because
Suharto had consolidated so much control
in Indonesia but also because he was
supported by the number-one superpower
in the world and that was the United
States and the United States has
supported him through all the years
whether a Republican or a democratic
administration right through to
President Clinton and the story that you
have there that I got out of the
Washington Post Indonesian police fire
at separatist demonstrators is a story
that's about protests their ongoing
protests all over Indonesia now and this
is in the western state of Papua West
Papua where the largest gold and copper
mining operation in the world is going
on and that is run by freeport-mcmoran
which is based in New Orleans Louisiana
but their people are protesting and the
Indonesian military gunned down seven of
them and Wiranto whom the New York Times
would have you believe is a moderate
military leader the man behind habibi
right now the president of Indonesia
called their protest treachery this is
what he's been calling any protest what
the military has continued to call
protests both in Indonesia and in
another place occupied Timor I've spent
time in Indonesia and East Timor
survived a massacre in East Timor in
1991 where I watched more than 250 to
marie's gunned down by Indonesian
soldiers using US weapons a u.s. m16s so
I know that relationship very well
between the United States and Indonesia
and what we are looking at today is
whether the military will remain in
power in Indonesia or whether the
pro-democracy movement will succeed and
not only kicking out Suharto
but in kicking out the military as well
and as a corollary what will happen with
East Timor which is illegally occupied
just last week the UN held its annual
decolonization hearings where people
like Jose a Ramos Horta who is the Nobel
Peace Prize winner from East Timor
testified and once again demanded
referendum in East Timor so that people
can decide their own future calling for
self-determination New York City good
morning good morning Amy I'm a big fan
of yours I'm involved with Dai and I met
you had the Columbia University's Chris
fair I don't know if you recognize my
voice or not anyway could you just
briefly enlighten a lot of the viewers
who might not be aware of it on the long
documented yet suppressed history of
collusion between the government and
media in terms of the Kohen tell probe
or MKULTRA program and other you know
operations of that nature
thanks well that's a tall order but one
thing the listeners referring to is the
counterintelligence program which is a
program set up by the FBI to
particularly target Black Panthers and
black activists and leading to the
deaths of many we see a lawsuit just in
the last month of Geronimo Pratt who
who's got out of prison after post to do
two decades in prison accused of killing
a woman many years ago when he said at
the time the FBI full knew knew well
where he was at Panther leader meetings
in Oakland because they had so carefully
monitored every move every phone call
and now he's suing the FBI in the Los
Angeles Police Department for the
counterintelligence program and the fact
that it put him behind bars for so many
years that's the counterintelligence
program MKULTRA I don't know a
tremendous amount about but it's about
the US government's experiments with LSD
and drugs
experimenting on unsuspecting citizens
Barstow California
good morning something interesting I
found in the paper on on the third core
sample she'll melt down in Antarctica
it's an Associated Press article horse
from the from holes drilled through
thousands of feet of ice in Antarctica
producers fossils that prove a massive
ice sheet icy in the polar region may
have melted completely as recently as
400,000 years ago and it ends the
findings said the researcher shows that
the southern oceans were warmer during
periods between major ice ages and 150
years of ocean warming sure sounds like
not much time with his 400,000 years and
I thought this would be picked up maybe
we're not having global warming maybe
it's a natural phenomenon that goes on
and these researchers were from Sweden
and the California Institute of
Technology and this report was the
finding being reported today in the
journal Science suggests that a huge
deposit known as the West Arctic ice
sheet goes through natural cycles of
milk and refreeze over thousands of
years and maybe the 150 years that the
global warming alarmist have been
talking about it's kind of a little
short time well I am NOT an expert on
the issues you're talking about but I
think global warming is a real issue and
it raises just following on this theme
that we've been talking about of
corporate control of information how
difficult it is to get accurate
information when you have scientists on
the payroll of large corporations I'll
switch it to another story although it's
a story around science and that is an
olestra which is a product that was just
recently released by Procter & Gamble
which is this large fat globule that is
so large your body can't absorb it and
so it goes right through your system
and it's being hailed as the new you
know diet chemical because you can put
it in potato chips you can use it as a
fat instead of having fatty potato chips
and your body won't absorb it the
problem is the body also won't absorb
vitamins that go along with it that are
fat soluble but the reason that I raised
that and why you made me think about
that is because when you want to do a
story on something like olestra the
corporation provides you with pages and
pages of top scientists around the
country Dean's of schools of Public
Health and very often if you question
them extensively you'll find out or if
they answer you honestly that they are
somehow on the payroll of that
corporation if not to have done one
study they might endow a chair at the
University and this means a lot this
helps people get professorships and so
it's really tough to get accurate
information and I put out a challenge to
journalists that every time you
interview an expert you should say where
that expert comes from and where they
have gotten their money and if they are
speaking about a particular drug or a
particular food product if they're
speaking about global warming to find
out if they are funded by any
corporation and if they've gotten money
because it's the only way the American
people can decide make critical
evaluations of the information they get
another of the Articles that you notice
this morning
Indian United States to meet this week
on nuclear issue in Dateline New Delhi
India in the US have begun diplomatic
moves aimed at narrowing their
differences on nuclear issues including
the global Test Ban Treaty officials
said the day she wanted to mention that
as a story about India you've also
earlier mentioned stories from Africa
and from Indonesia a number of
international stories I want to ask in a
general sense about international news
on Pacifica compared to other media
outlets well I think we do a good deal
more international news than most news
international news brought to you by any
other place I think it's down to
something like 2% in the rest of the
media and we really see the world as one
entity and it's very much connected to
us here at home it's not a story way out
there in Nigeria first of all there are
thousands of Nigerians who live in this
country but all
so because of our connections
particularly unfortunately to
dictatorships and what is the connection
between them I think and the glue are
well weapons manufacturers that want to
sell their weapons nuclear the nuclear
weapons industry something that's been
lost a lot in the whole discussion about
China when Jiang's the Menten came to
the United States and had that big state
dinner in Washington if you looked at
the guest list many of them were from
the nuclear industry because of
corporations like Westinghouse which
owns CBS and General Electric which owns
NBC wanting to move into China and sell
nuclear if not weapons nuclear
technology which can be used for nuclear
weapons and I think we have to look very
carefully at that and just talking about
those media connections that's why we
don't get a lot of that kind of coverage
on on television but I see local issues
very much connected to international
issues workers see it for goodness sake
I mean people see every day we have this
GM strike people see every day how
companies will leave this country and
they will go to another country where
they can exploit workers there and not
pay them enough not pay health benefits
and workers here can't compete and I
think we have to take a real look about
the kind of society we want and the kind
of responsible companies that we want to
operate here it's about five or six
minutes left with Amy Goodman of
Pacifica Radio the host of democracy now
when does your program air well it goes
out on the satellite every morning at
9:00 Eastern Standard Time and it either
airs live on stations or they can just
run it through the day so they run it at
different times throughout the day New
York City good morning good boy name is
Mark Berenson calling Amy we know you
have spoken out about democracy or its
limitations in Latin America in the past
few weeks there have been many newspaper
articles about our daughter Lori
Berenson who has been wrongfully
incarcerated in Peru now for over two
and a half years the Peruvian Prime
Minister a well respected constitutional
lawyer has said that Lori should be
pardoned and sent home because of all
overwhelming flaws and lack of due
process in the
Terry tribunal that convicted her in
secret for treason against a country
that is not even her own the President
of Peru Alberto Fujimori
has refused to listen to his own prime
minister the other day I read that
ambassador Denis Jed in Peru the
American ambassador pointed out that he
believes Laurie has been singled out by
Peru for especially harsh treatment
because she is an American citizen we
agree with that were upset about that we
would like to know what you think about
the role of the u.s. in this case and
two comments in general about the
situation in Peru well thank you very
much for calling in Marc Berenson as the
father as he said of Laurie Berenson who
has been in jail now for two and a half
years and Laurie has been sentenced to
life in prison by a hooded judge where
she or her lawyers could not challenge
the evidence they could not question the
witnesses and she was just thrown in
this prison in the mountains of Peru
which is freezing cold the animal prison
it is quite something what has developed
the prime minister of Peru saying that
she should be released and that she
could not should not have been charged
with treason and it's an example also of
how Peruvians are treated thousands of
them tried in these military tribunals
what happened that led to the charges
well she was charged with being involved
with a group called the MRT a but she
never got a chance to challenge those
charges and as Mark Berenson just said
the even the US ambassador just said
that she never said she was a part of
that group and she couldn't see the
evidence that was presented against her
and what many human rights activists are
calling for is for her and other people
in Peru to be tried in civilian courts
given a fair trial so that they can be
found innocent or guilty based on the
evidence I actually got a chance to
question about Roe fujimori just last
week because he came to New York but he
has remained steadfast and he says that
he will not release her but I think this
is just a case of grassroots activists
around the world having to put more
pressure but also a challenge to the US
government to challenge
this government that does hold military
tribunals and imprison so many thousands
of people through these secret trials
the US has a very close relationship
with Peru and the US has the power to
press for people like Lori to be
released so it's really up to the State
Department now and it's really up to
grassroots activists to put pressure
there I see this is another publication
he brought is that the kind of story you
would read about in this report of the
Americas yes it's the Nakhla report on
the Americas the North American Congress
on Latin America very interesting
publication that comes out of New York
and they have done a number of stories
on oppression in Peru in fact in the
last few days they've been stories on
Peru and how journalists are going being
gone after there's a lot of repression
against journalists politicians that
Fujimori doesn't like we have to look at
the u.s. relationship with these kind of
military regimes around the world Omaha
Nebraska good morning good morning I
hope nobody's asked this question yet I
I'm curious to know how Amy would
respond to those people who claimed that
the issue of campaign finance is mainly
a free speech issue right argument
promulgated a lot and and I don't buy it
but I I guess I don't I can't put my
finger on why I don't buy it but it just
sounds bogus to me well I think I agree
with you and I think we have to turn it
around if giving money is a matter of
free speech that it's everyone's right
to give money what happens to those who
don't have money it means that they
don't have that speech I mean that's the
serious issue and I think that's the
flaw for example even the ACL u--'s
arguments because they are very much
proponents of that we have to look at a
system that gives people free speech who
you know have the pocketbooks and we're
talking about very vast reserves of
money so I think it has to be challenged
I think the whole system has to be
overhauled and of course there are many
who agree with that and it's just a
matter of them you know their voices
being louder than the pocketbooks of
those fighting I'm going to look at
three notes that came on the internet
this morning I have to do with the
question of diversity that we talked
about earlier this is from Doug and
Tucson I
miss Goodman I find your call for more
diversity on radio stations quite
disturbing you would have some agency
mandate what we listen to she implies
that shows like Rush Limbaugh are
inherently evil because they're funded
by corporations and here's another note
this is from Diane Martin in Florissant
Missouri I want to ask miss Goodman why
it's so important to have diversity of
reporters in reporting the news it seems
to me that a reporter's job is to report
the news and the facts of the story and
not put their feelings or slant into the
report and then there's also this short
note from Michael Mathis he said how
should the media be regulated with
respect to diversity well I mean I think
these are very serious issues and the
the last person who wrote in and saying
that it people should just be objective
people journalists are people and people
come with their own perspectives and we
have to accept that and their own
backgrounds and that informs what they
do what stories they think are important
there are thousands of stories out there
you only see a very select few in the
media because a small group of people
usually white men with money decide that
they are important and I think that when
you have it diversity doesn't guarantee
a diverse point of view I mean racial
diversity doesn't guarantee it but once
you open up that window you are more
likely to have different points of view
and not only talking about racial
diversity but economic diversity as well
where people come from you know saying
should we go there to do that story in
when I think of that when talking about
Manhattan where so many of the reporters
love concentrated in Manhattan and they
say do we go up there to cover them in
the South Bronx that affects the kind of
coverage you get and I agree that you
want to have a well-rounded newsroom I
think that we want to if you want to get
at fairness and objectivity you want to
bring as many people into the
decision-making positions to decide what
is news as possible Durant Oklahoma good
morning good morning hi what I'd like to
do as a conservative I'd like to point
out that even though I disagree with you
on your analysis almost every problem I
like to point out where that we have
common goals and one of them is you
brought up the bovine grass or not
and I also believe that these hormones
are bad and also the the different types
of antibiotics are put in the feed and
chiquita chemicals is down there but
it's not the job of the company to
police the food it's the job of the FDA
and as long as we've got the FDA running
around having a war on tobacco's we're
not gonna get any protection for our
children everyone knows that tobacco's
bad durant where where do you read about
this story which story in particular
about the growth hormone it's something
that interests you where have you found
that story before in the newspaper
magazines oh I've seen it in
agricultural our agricultural articles I
know I've also had some experience with
raising a livestock and I know the
different kinds of things that go in
there we you know it's interesting you
raise this issue because the USDA the US
Department of Agriculture in the last
year has put out proposed standards for
organic labeling never before have there
been uniform standards for what is
organic and there is a burgeoning a
consumer movement I mean people want to
get fresh foods that aren't contaminated
by additives or toxins and they didn't
think they would get very much response
but among the things they were including
in what could be labeled organic and
these were just proposals were were
things that were bioengineered like RGBA
rb/gh things that were irradiated foods
that were irradiated and also the use of
toxic sludge as a kind of mulch on the
food and farming and they got an
overwhelming response hundreds of
thousands of people have called in and
really turned the USDA around now people
are not completely happy with what the
USDA has come up with but on those three
issues dan Glickman the Secretary of the
USDA has been forced to say or a they
will not be included in organic labeling
they're still fighting about what will
be considered organic but I think these
are issues that cut across conservative
and liberal lines people any
we're want to have information so that
we can make our own decisions
I think it's the responsibility of the
government to ensure we get that
information and it's the responsibility
of corporations to be honest about the
chemicals that they're using and when
for example a pesticide is banned in
this country a corporation should not be
able to dump it on a country a
developing country like Honduras and
hurt the people there Tampa good morning
yeah you know I'm kind of concerned
about global warming I think that if you
really put the finger on the main
problem it's capitalism is the enemy of
the earth
you know democracy is what we need but
there's there's too many automobiles and
if the Chinese start building little
cars and running them over in China
there's not gonna be nothing left of
this earth and I think the earth is kind
of an oxygen making machine we're slowly
tearing down another thing about Vietnam
is Colin will let you go on that point
since we're about out of time
Aimee goodness well yeah thanks for your
call I'm concerned about global warming
also and sport utility vehicles and
these huge gas guzzlers that we seem to
have gone back to it is critical that we
all protect the environment and that we
all take care of it and you're right as
as the u.s. expands and companies go
abroad and you look at China with a
billion people it's very important we
come up with international plans about
what we want to do with this planet Amy
Goodman is the host of democracy now on
Pacifica Radio originally from Bay Shore
New York thanks very much for being with
us thank you